before he heads off into the sunset with
his fat government pension Dr Anthony
fauci making the rounds again and is
don't blame me tour the nation's top doc
who repeatedly lied to the American
people at the onset of the pandemic is
now worried about his legacy
I think the misconception is that I was
misleading people you know to say that I
who have been advised at a seven
presidents and have never ever veered
one way or the other from an ideological
standpoint for somebody to say that you
know I'm political yeah political I mean
that's completely crazy would you take
back what you said about masks obviously
the guidance changed but you were but
you were very definitive you said
there's absolutely no reason for people
to be wearing masks yeah I mean sure if
I had to do it over again of course I
would have analyzed it a little bit
better
did you catch there was a CD player in
the back of that room come on man
correct what comment on the CD player
are you on fauci's interview I you're
done
oh
but oh you want me to comment no I want
to talk about the CD player I don't I I
don't want to talk about it I don't have
any thoughts on it but I will could I
comment on fauci whatever you want all
right so he saw the retreat he saw the
retreat in the coronaviruses and he
decided to become like Jeff Goldblum in
the fly and he decided to become the
virus himself so he's like Dr Jekyll and
Mr kovid so he's everywhere omnipresent
and it's up to us the media right to
social distance right we have to stop
giving fauci the sound bites because we
need to do a one month shutdown against
against uh the fauci virus because it's
clear that we're spreading it but there
is good news for fauci I just read the
Boston University researchers have
developed a deadlier coveted strain in a
lab by adding a spike protein from the
Omicron variant uh uh to with to the
original Wuhan strain 80 percent more
deadly it's just what we needed because
we need to kill more people so we're
bringing the gain of function research
to Boston exactly
I'm going to play some sound for you he
continued Dana
she's going to talk about school
closures he got a little defensive
listen
way too high a price yeah I would say
that what we should realize and have
realized that there will be deleterious
collateral consequences they always come
back and say fauci was responsible for
closing schools I had nothing to do
what annoyed me most about that comment
is not fouchy because we know Eli CD
player Yeah Carl who's supposed to Bone
up on his homework didn't come back with
example after example of him saying the
United Kingdom schools the schools the
schools
how did he not know to do that well it's
interesting because I read in the fox
news.com piece today so you can see that
there were times throughout the last two
years it's been a long time two years
where vouchers say we've got to get the
schools open but then they never took
action to do that and this we know that
the teachers union was emailing with the
CDC and saying we don't want the schools
to get open and remember that's when the
CDC director Michelle wallenski said I
think school should be open and the
White House Press Secretary said she's
just speaking in her personal capacity
she doesn't really speak for them so
without you at the time he could have at
any time in fact you said open the
schools tomorrow because he was so
revered and people said oh okay let's do
that but instead not only just the mask
thing that um Jonathan Carl brought up
what about the fact that the six feet
social distancing was just pulled out of
thin air it wasn't based on science so
now that's one of the reasons you had
all the kids not be able to be at school
together plus the other thing is he
really pushed to get the American Rescue
plan done in order to like don't open
the schools until this gets passed right
but how much of that money has been
spent 96 also in the category of no one
listens to me anymore I've been saying
for 18 months they should stop doing
interviews and there's a lot of
diminishing returns on his interviews
and on my advice why are we still
interviewing fauci if the pandemic is
over
well I think that uh I think people are
looking for fauci to show a little
humility I think what they'd like him to
say is look look we didn't we didn't
have everything right I didn't get
everything right but he can't he can't
be humble you know instead he says I who
have been advisor to seven presidents
you know I mean there's such arrogance
it's almost like he's talking about
himself in the third person but he says
I'm not political at all and this whole
thing that Dana was talking about with
the teachers and Rachel wolinski well
what was what was fauci doing sitting on
the sidelines sitting in the back of the
room I mean he could very well have said
no wait a minute this is how it should
be done he's acting like he had no role
in it and you know look at what Senator
Rand Paul is saying you know like how is
it that your net worth has doubled
during the pandemic and what about you
don't need a mask that was political so
that they could have more masks for
other people for the doctors and you
know our kids suffered so much that it's
going to take until 2 2026 for them to
catch up and finally I mean he had no
problem criticizing Republicans no
problem criticizing Trump but you know
he's not a political guy yeah of course
not
the judge makes an excellent point all
you want from the doctor is to say
listen I was trying to save lives I was
giving my best recommendation as a
scientist as a doctor I did the best we
could isn't that what the people deserve
to hear not all this defensiveness
well there are bits and pieces of that
in there but it should be one cohesive
statement and he does have a long career
to point back to to say I'm not a
political figure that's very easy to do
he sat next to Republicans and Democrats
and made big Health Care decisions with
them and was right most of the time I I
don't know why that was an interview
that he wanted to do it feels just
personal at this point I mean covet
isn't even ranking on the polls now
right one or two people I think it's an
important issue there everyone is
thankful that our kids are back in
school
um I I can't even count the number of
people who've told me that they now live
by a no testing policy and these are
people who are liberals we're happy to
be shut down War masks continue to wear
masks places because they don't want to
not be able to go to work for 10 days or
whatever it is or because this is
manifesting thank God and most of us
have been vaccinated as a light flew and
we're going to have to live with it and
probably get vaccinated or boosted once
a year so it it doesn't help anyone I
would love for people to just be honest
about it we'll learn from it there will
be another one of these unfortunately
whether it's you know created in a
Boston lab or a foreign
all right I don't mean to belabor the
point but I mean if you're going to
follow the science you can't have a CD
player I don't know CD has extra
excellent sound no it doesn't yes it
does that's good on your phone
it's medieval basically say he was the
science right yeah
very happy he is the science maybe you
should interview him about a series he's
a scratched CD hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else